et pour en parler en direct avec nous
ils se mettent kurtovitch il est
historien spécialiste de la nouvelle
calédonie bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors comment va
s'articuler ce déconfinement pro facile
bonjour madame bien les mesures
spécifiques ont été maintenus le seront
jusqu'au 9 avril
et parallèlement à ça notre gouvernement
travaille dans trois tiré d'abord il met
à la disposition des plus de 65 ans pour
l'instant neuf mille doses de vaccin
environ par semaine qui sont fournis
gratuitement par l'état
en suite de cela le gouvernement
collégial nous avons un gouvernement
collégial entamé une réflexion sur la
question de savoir s'il faut rendre
obligatoire la vaccination pour
certaines catégories de personnes par
exemple celles qui travaillent à
l'aéroport international celle qui
travaille dans l'hôpital donc c'est une
question qui commence à interroger
l'opinion publique et certains partis
politiques et hommes politiques et enfin
le gouvernement travaille à un
en somme un styliste va s'inspirer de
celui a été mieux au point pour la
nouvelle zélande et que nous
connaissions un peu pour les cyclones
avec des deux red alert et des degrés de
précaution suivant le danger exprimé par
tel ou tel événement qui surviendrait à
la faveur des dépistages
donc voilà c'est sur ces trois choses là
le décompte la nouvelle calédonie va
pouvoir se pérenniser parce que notre
gouvernement reste dans la stratégie que
notre pays reste un pays sans coville
selon vous la nouvelle calédonie nous a
montré que c'était possible de maîtriser
la circulation du bien
s non justement
nous essayons qu'il n'y a pas de
circulation de virus et que grâce au
système de quarantaine les personnes
susceptibles d'avoir la maladie sont
repérés dès la 14 ème je veux dire comme
nous en avions parlé la dernière fois au
début quand se confirme en deuxième
quand il filme ans a été mis en place
la bulle que nous avions avec wallis et
futuna en quelque sorte a éclaté et le
virus est arrivé dans le pays
mais grâce à la au travail de la
direction de ne les intéresses sociales
de la nouvelle calédonie les personnes
susceptibles d'avoir la maladie ont été
identifiés ont été enterrés les
personnes contacts ont été testés ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui notre gouvernement
estime après l'avis des experts que le
risque est très très faible que le coc
vide circulant nouvelle calédonie donc
nouvelle calédonie comme on le dit
territoire kovy de free c'est bien ça
oui voilà on peut aussi dire sans
coville est qu est-ce selon vous qu'est
ce qui explique ce taux très faible de
contaminer voire pas du tout d'ailleurs
il s'explique parce que l'année dernière
dès le début dès le début alors que
notre pays est ouvert sur l'extérieur
nous accueillons plusieurs centaines de
milliers de croisiéristes par an cent
mille touristes mais on a un commerce
tourné à l'international qui est assez
dense donc nous sommes pas à payer isolé
mais par contre dès que l'annoncent de
la maladie qui est intervenu tout de
suite les autorités de gouvernementales
les autorités coutumières on ce tome
isolé le pays isolé comme nous venons de
le faire pour le deuxième co
peaufinement où tous les vols
internationaux ont été stoppés y compris
même les vols double donc seulement
immédiats du pays qui a permis
finalement
que le coc vite ne sortent pas ensemble
des hôtels ou les personnes susceptibles
d'être contaminés étaient mis en 14 ans
il se met derrière j de personnes
terminé très rapidement aller dit ça il
s'agit des personnes qui avaient un
besoin impérieux de venir en nouvelle
calédonie pour des nécessités de notre
économie de notre administration
ou alors des calédoniens qui rentraient
au pays c'est seul sait ce c'est ce
voyez ces voyages lie cette circulation
là qu'ils avaient été maintenus et qui
va reprendre à partir d'aujourd'hui nous
sommes vendredi aujourd'hui il se met
trop vite merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et spécialiste de la nouvelle
calédonie mercière